democratic gubernatorial candidate stacy
abrams seen maskless while visiting a
georgia elementary school this weekend
look at her there she's posing for a
picture with a room full of young
children who you guessed it were all
wearing masks and she's not the only one
democratic congressman jamal bowman was
caught maskless during a photo opt at a
new new york high school as well the
students in the photo again wear a mask
new york city mayor eric adams also
pictured without a mask despite a state
wide indoor mask mandate this was just
days after he doubled down on mass
mandates for schools a michigan
congresswoman a vulnerable democrat
alyssa slotkin pictured masklas at an
event yesterday nearly every other
person in the picture had one on
wow
charlie i don't know if we have that
picture that we can pull back up of
stacy abrams it is just stunning when i
saw this over the weekend i thought this
is the picture
that the defining picture of the radical
left during the pandemic look at that
look at those kids this is a picture of
betrayal of america's children yeah
yeah by her own definition
she apparently does not care about
children and wants uh to infect them all
you know which of course is not really
true uh and but it does reveal the total
absurdity of all of this and i guess at
some level we should be grateful to
people like stacey abrams and all aoc
all of the hypo hypocrites that have uh
we have seen since the beginning of all
these mandates we should be sort of
grateful to them because the reason that
i think uh america is swiftly moving
away from these mandates moving away you
know realizing that the masks don't
really uh generally help the mandates
don't help
is because uh is because of this sort of
hypocrisy from the very people who have
argued most vociferously for the
mandates yeah that's right um look at
this
i saw this this morning day and this is
crazy a tweet from daybook look at the
timing here
job opportunity stacey abrams
gubernatorial campaign seeks a social
media platforms director to manage the
day-to-day posting an approval on the
campaign's social media accounts i bet
she is looking for that she doesn't
realize maybe that she would have been a
hero if none of those children had had
mask on there are about three dozen of
them in the photo
many of them wearing masks by the way
those cloth masks that don't work
exactly so i will quote carol markowitz
the great carol markowitz of the new
york post children shouldn't have been
wearing masks last week last month last
year you know the drill but this will
ultimately come back to bite all of
these democrats because they took this
anti-science position due to politics
and as carol said ironically it will be
the politics that forces them to let go
she can blame
she can blame whomever for this but she
had to have known i'm sitting here in
front of three dozen kids who are massed
up and i'm not wearing them and it looks
bad and we're destroying the development
of these children the development and
the she put out the picture
yeah and she put out the picture digging
which is crazy most of the time it's you
know someone who snaps a photo of you
not having the mask on and that's how
you get outed but in this case she
proactively posted this harris and
harris you knew this was coming the
hypocrisy slow scroll the list is
growing uh let's pull it and go to you
i think i think that we should put some
like dell music behind it you know
things that slow scroll after some
hypocrisy
oh i still don't believe adele didn't
know that concert was going to be
canceled days before those people spent
all that money trying to see her
different day i'm still living in it
though
look
you know stacy abrams has not learned
the finer political gift obviously
of
well if there are children in the room i
must be the very best version of myself
oh yeah that's not about politics that's
about adulting
so if she really cares about those
children she would want to mask up if
she believes that masking up with with a
cloth mask which many of them as dagon
pointed out were in will protect anybody
in the room even though the cdc says now
they know that it won't
but however it would shake out wouldn't
she have them in mind first before
anything else that's adulting that's
what that is and if in fact you walk in
and you want to take a picture and
everybody should be masked then bring
your own because you know sometimes
these little ones aren't as prepared as
they should be or they keep touching
their mask and you can help them that
moment of help and teaching
she missed and then she filled their
mind with hypocrisy
and full-fledged
regalia because she takes the picture
and then she deletes it and that teaches
the kids in the photo well mommy the
picture's not up with
with stacey abrams anymore did i do
something wrong no honey she did
and she was so guilty about it she
thought the one thing that we know can't
happen emily let's say it together it's
on the internet you can't erase it
exactly
our slow scroll is getting longer and
longer
it does need music i love that great
idea harris we'll work on that i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis